alright let's get started so we are
streaming this on Twitch and we're doing
something really crazy here which is
that we are letting the world eavesdrop
on part of what I for example actually
do every day which is designing pieces
of Wolfram language and so on so this is
I think our title is behind the scenes
in real world software development this
is the pilot episode which is another
way of saying this may be a total
disaster
the particular topic where we're doing
I've had a bunch of other design reviews
today but the particular one we're doing
here is making real time connections to
a mail server initially through the IMAP
protocol and so we are talking about
we've had several previous meetings and
there's some pieces of code that have
been written and we are going to
continue looking at this okay so let's
see so I have should have here the
result of connection to mail server are
we still are we still planning to use
this mail server Connect thing or are we
planning to do this differently for him
it's up for discussion but I think it's
useful to have something like that but
perhaps it would look like Cloud Connect
why why Cloud Connect I mean so ok so
but this is going what would the server
part mean anyway I mean it's you know
mail is presumably on a server but who
knows whether it's on a remote server or
some local thing or something else so if
I go so what happens if I say so what
are the what are the possible things say
do we have a list so this was no well
that's definitely a bad result yeah
could you connect again do we need to
connect again no that's working fine ok
all right so ok so there the folders
show up as by the way for him there's a
lot of background noise for you but the
so the folders show up like file folders
here and it's not what we decided we
wanted or we have this whole folder
object concept we're not sure let's take
a look okay so you wanted to show me
what happens with the search right ok so
let's try this so what are this going to
do this is going to do that since
yesterday so what is that that doesn't
seem right
I'm sorry you need to connect to a
folder for so you need to do ms Inbox
love quotes and books like that upper
case yes okay and now you want to do
could you name it a variables like inbox
equal ms inbox
okay and now do you mail search often
box okay and then what am i doing then
the same Association here yes
this is not going quickly what is that I
not quite sure I think you may have some
weird character in my email some weird
character is sending me some email with
real characters um
okay is this gonna work at all it should
maybe you have too much earth is this
newsletters gr compliances does not
exist
yeah so that's sort of the output so
what is this is this incoming mail or is
this oh this is your inbox that's how
your inbox looks for the past two days
oh I see so this is my most recent three
emails okay
so there's a whole bunch of so if I if I
were to say here so this is a data set
of that inbox that's pretty cool yes
okay so for example if I'm so what are
these what is this display this is nice
the summary looks nice so if I if I were
to take for example here let me name
this let's go ahead and name that result
in box data set equals that and now
let's say in box D s of all comma what
was that thing date was that D no no no
not this of the second column
I think that was date okay so now I can
say why boy where's the scrolling so
slowly this must have to do with the way
that twitch is interacting with
everything um so if I say date histogram
what is going on here this is not even
scrolling what is happening
well one of the rules for doing this on
Twitch is that it doesn't actually
interfere with us getting work done and
this is unfortunately a problem because
okay so what does this mean so why does
it so it's got something from September
11th which is crazy and most of this
stuff is much more recent yes that
probably is parsing error on my hand all
right so if I say differences of % 11 I
should be getting that's weird
um I should get okay ah well I want
minus of that and then no what the heck
is this that should be what are these
dates do you see do you see what I'm
seeing here so this is these should be
the dates between successive messages
right the times between successive
messages yes well why are they both
negative and positive how can there be a
message I mean it depends what that
field is actually representing so if I
say typing properly you understand the
question so let's get the first 10 of
these and now
57 52 51 those are all going down so if
I say differences there
okay that's fine but then why do we end
up getting so much A+ that must be a
timezone problem yeah look at that that
I bet that what's that
yeah it's likely time zones are not
being done correctly right so that was
Jim t minus four so if I say 20 here
okay so fine so we've got some issue
with that
um yeah look at that so that is there
but they all say GMT minus four but I
bet they're not all GMT minus 4 right
yeah yeah okay so all right so let's but
what we really want to concentrate on is
the design here so I mean this is very
cool and I mean we can make a histogram
presumably of the things in line 14 gosh
this is scrolling like crazy slow
okay so mildly interesting that's
probably the actual results I don't know
what these are here and that's a glitch
they're probably from that term from
that thing that was miss parsed okay so
now if I say for example let's see if I
take that original inbox this thing so I
say take inbox D s comma three for
example okay um so that is the top three
entries in my inbox it's pretty cool it
almost looks like Apple Mail um alright
let's take a look at what's actually
here so you have so what is this is this
the complete Association of what was
what we were able to parse yes so it is
the envelope information and attachments
all those things that we can actually
parse and it also contains the message
itself with the text message not the
HTML Beth
so what happens if there's our
attachment if you scroll today then you
will probably see if it had okay so this
is one this is that third message there
okay so what am I seeing what's it
attached there's no attachment okay
so question for folks who know about
email here so this this is just some
string and there's no useful way that we
can break up that string is that correct
and is the message ID the thing with
angle brackets or is the message ID the
thing without angle brackets I believe
it is with the angle bracket by Jason
would know
okay so the the those are part of the ID
okay so what is the sequence ID that's
the identification of the mail in your
inbox so if you wanted to grab a part of
the particular message you have to give
that key and that's useful but perhaps
okay okay so this two thing here is why
is this okay so that's a list and each
one is broken like that is that what we
really want to do well it makes sense
because then you can filter rather
quickly
you see if you want particular domain
and sometimes they might not be present
but wait a minute don't we have in our
mail I mean if we look at just what is
the thing and box the mbox format the
what what what what is the mail import
format that we that you are using for
this not using emls there right want to
look at why is this so slow what is
happening here it's crazy
okay so when in this case to list it's
just a list of strings isn't it and to
name list right so we want to follow the
exact same conventions yes yes okay so
if this is I mean then this should be
called two rules or some such other
thing and by the way the CC line is is
capital C lowercase C and that should be
CC list and I don't so why is this
important not the same as the importer
that we're using for other things do you
understand my question
now okay look you this if I took this
piece of my mailbox and I imported it
through the EML importer I would get
some association with a bunch of fields
right yes okay so I'm asking why are
these fields not the same as the fields
over here right because there are a few
things first of all this is not the
whole message this is EML so once you
actually get the email we are not
fetching emails we are looking at the
search results so that's why it's a
little bit different okay so fine but so
so one of the things we need to do is
make sure that it's the same so that for
example if you took this and exported it
again for example if we gave this to
send mail right that it would just work
yes okay so
what we've got here is a to list so what
you're saying is that it's useful to
break the two thing into it into an
association of some kind right yes okay
so we should allow that also for EML
importing and I think we've got a to
list here and maybe we say to list rules
or some such other thing to represent
this fully you know fully broken apart
version does that make sense yes who is
responsible for the ml importer okay do
we want to get him to join this meeting
okay um okay okay fine so let's say I
want to get so with the summary where do
I get the actual text of the message
okay so with this this is another one of
your Association thing me Diggs here so
my suggestion is in the summary view
that you're getting well I don't know
what you want to do here look we I think
it is better in this summary view what
happened here so this is this is what
you got from looking at a particular
folder is that correct yes um and that's
everything about that folder is that
true is that the complete so what I'm
suggesting is something that would
duplicate some of the information in
that folder
to have something which has both the two
lists and the two list rules correct yes
um which is a little crazy but and now
by the way why did this not turn into
something like this
why did that not turn into a sub
Association in the data set my question
do we know I mean maybe we should try
let's try this one here so that is
percent twenty sub two
okay again for some bizarre reason this
doesn't okay now why did this what is
this doing this is the to list here I
don't understand why something it ends
up in my inbox has John in the to list
that probably is a parsing error or it
you received it as a CC but I didn't
know you did look oh I see parth
responded and okay okay fair enough
alright so now how do I see the text of
number two here there is a message to it
so it's oh I see there so I see so I
simply click that message thing yeah oh
that's cool
okay I'm actually interested know what
this says
okay so this is just the standard
formatting from dataset is that correct
the text is yes precisely it's just a
string yeah but you haven't broken it
into these quoting blocks and things
like this right no okay all right well
this is rather beautiful all right so
let's go back then and look at so how
did you make this summary I don't
understand oh the summary is just
another string is that right no it's
actually a grid box to make it look nice
and pretty
so if I actually extract it what will I
see
so if I say it's probably a great box
with item styles and all those fancy
I mean is this why is this echo not
echoing this is just so crazy okay so
it's a bunch of weird nonsense okay well
it looks beautiful but is this really
what we want and how do we think about
this I mean maybe we should have this
wrapped in some kind of things so that
if you actually get it out like this it
has an interpretation box that causes it
to come out in some different way let's
let's investigate that okay but let's
come back to our main discussion okay so
this is there's the first thing you're
showing is you're showing so if I were
to do a search the search results would
come out in this kind of form as well as
that correct yes you know it occurs to
me that for our purposes if you are
trying to extract things it would
probably be useful to number if we can
do that in some elegant way to actually
number also have some identifiers here
and by the way this non name nun doesn't
seem promising I mean that should surely
be missing of some kind yes but but
again again I really think that the
sender thing should just say you know
parth P it will you know parth
angle bracket path P at whatever rather
than this form here so I tend to think
that what is returned I mean maybe we
can kind of hack it a bit and have the
early parts of this some of this
association that you're likely to see
here be the sender and then later on
have the sender rules but I don't really
understand what the difference in sender
and from is what's the difference in
Center and from because you could do a
relay I believe Jason would know
interesting can you comment on that
person from can be kind of an arbitrary
okay so in our ml importer how are we
finding the genuine sender or do we not
have that that did Shawn join no such
method you find Shawn Sushma you're on
mute
she may not be back from tracking them
down yet um okay does anybody else know
the answer to that what what Shawn is on
his way okay um okay so we've got a
question for him that will ask when he
shows up okay so let's go back here
- okay so again remember our our overall
objective so we want to be able to
analytics so for example yeah top
recipients top things like this so for
example if I want to do a graph of male
recipients here what I would do is I
would extract see that's actually going
to be a mess and that's a good reason to
have the complete I guess I could get
the complete sender associations there
and I could look at so what would I need
to do in my inbox right now with
whatever it is what would I need to do
to extract the what I'm looking for is
the the graph of male recipients so that
means who is in common right between if
I extract the two lists am I making
sense that right that I would be
extracting from that inbox yes I just
wish it was echoing my keystrokes better
inbox D s I would extract all comma - is
that correct okay so that's a whole long
list of yes oh great
okay
fascinating um well that might okay all
right so anyway so this is this is the
so how would you make a graph from these
email recipients so this is showing each
one of these we kind of want to join
what what do we want to do we want to
make something where we show for each
you know who is who'd Co receives email
with who else am I making sense um and
how would we do that so one thing I can
do here it's just a simple gosh this
keystroke failure to echo is horrifying
okay so now I've got this is so this is
a real straightforward thing this is the
number of recipients okay so that shows
the distribution of number of recipients
of mail that I'm receiving it's kind of
interesting alright so this is so what
you've got here seems to be reasonably
effective in terms of so let's look at
domains actually so let's go ahead and
say so how would I extract the domain so
for each of these what I would want to
do just just for fun I'd like to see the
domains that these are going to I guess
so that's line 25 so I mean I'm just
doing this as an example
normal 925 and then I probably want to
say flatten that and then for each of
those I want to extract okay so that's a
great big long list and so for each of
those I want to extract the domain
actually I probably could make this a
little bit simpler and then I just want
to say counts
all right maybe I can make come a word
cloud so this will be people who might
have cc'd me I mean who knows what these
are okay that's kind of cool
which name so you sir domain I guess so
was that what was that what the fields
were that's true
but but so I mean but that's an argument
for what for heme has done here of
separating you know putting these things
as separate elements in the Association
right so that you can choose to only
look at the genuine user but we don't
have a similar thing did did Sean
finally join us okay so we have a
question about the EML importer so right
now so first question is the genuine
sender rather than the I don't know what
that what is it it X and from I don't
know what what I don't know what they've
there's a from header or that will
basically you can put whatever you want
for the name of the person if you want
actually determine where it comes from
you have to look though received headers
okay that would be the elements of like
delivery chain Records where is that so
is that is that part of what we are what
the important okay but so why aren't we
then so for him has chosen here to have
a much more exposed version of the
genuine sender right yes so we probably
want that so maybe Jason couldn't say
something about that do we how much do
we want to expose the genuine sender it
seems useful to expose the genuine
sender right rather than to hide it
under some delivery chain records is it
obvious from the delivery chain record
who the original sender was okay but is
it unique and well-defined or is it
something where you know I mean if you
look at a piece of spam for example what
will that typically look like
well that is unspookable or is it not
unspookable okay but can you see more
than the domain can you see the whole
name you know user name domain or can
you just see the domain no you can't
really guarantee who sent it you just
know where it came from the domain that
it came from right okay so but you can
put whatever you want for the name okay
but for him what are you picking up when
you say sender and your stuff I am
picking the actual sender where it came
from the domain the domain but what
about the username that's the part of
IMAP IETF RFC lookup so I'll have to
look into that to make sure so this is
so IMAP gives you some way to access
what it considers the sender is that
correct yes exactly okay which we
believe is coming from the delivery
chain records is that right yes
okay so we need to figure out how that
works and whatever it is that I map is
doing we should expose it more in the ml
importer right and we should but I think
for purposes here we should hide it to
the same level that it's been hidden in
the ml importer that is we should
concentrate on the Fromme list that is
you know what I'm saying the the from
well here so that the from line that is
the as as given from line which might be
spoofed if somebody's you know playing a
game or whatever else does that make
sense yes I think cuz that's what you
typically see that's what I will see in
my mail client typically is the Fromme
line as spoofed or whatever is that
isn't that correct yes the okay fine so
go ahead sir what necklace but what is
what is sander I mean sander is what
Fahim says comes from the IMAP protocol
[Music]
so for instance if you are if you send
something to the secretary yup you are
the secretary is the sender and you that
you dictate to the message you are the
from something like that so when you
search something through a program
somebody sometimes the program puts
itself into sender but by the time you
are reading in i'ma they are completely
obscure and arbitrary strings there is
something else that is called the
envelope in emails right hello is within
right so I'm parsing the envelope so I
ask for particularly envelope that's the
outfit over there so there is actually
an IMAP command which says give me the
envelope information okay look so so
what we're saying is there are three
different things here and the most
important okay so there seem to be
multiple criteria first of all in you
know in our mail handling system here in
our sort of IMAP based mail handling
system it better be the case that the
that what you see is more or less what
you would see in a typical mail client
okay which I don't believe is the case
right now first point second point is
whatever we do there has to be
compatible with what we do in the email
importer and it also has to be
compatible with what send mail does and
I believe right now Sean maybe you can
say speak to this that what send mail
does is is compatible with what EML does
what the email and Porter does is that
correct it is correct we're just looking
at the front header
no I understand but effectively send
mail is like an EML exporter is that
true
how does
you know Jenny I think well basically we
use Java mail to construct the message
and actually construct a message in Java
mail and then just send it to the server
okay but that construction comes from
the EML so we have the original Wolfram
language association that has a bunch of
these fields right and from those fields
we are constructing something which will
be so what should happen is there should
be a round trip that's possible where
you go you know from something which is
an association here through to arrives
in my mailbox then from my mailbox I
live connect to the mailbox and then I
should be able to get these associations
back from you know the association that
I get out here should be identical to
the Association that I put in and then
sent through sent through send mail does
that make sense yeah yes but I don't
think it's true right now so that's one
thing that we need to make sure of so
who is so Sushma I think that's for you
to figure out to make sure that that
happens okay and who is let's see who
we're not actively doing much on mail
import and export are we no okay and so
who is fine okay well so there may be
some tweaks needed there may not be I
mean I think we were pretty careful in
the design of this so I think this is
probably going to be pretty decent with
the exception that you guys are pointing
out that these various so there are
three things as I understand it there's
a from there's a sender and there's
stuff inside the envelope is that
correct I mean I only knew about the
from and the stuff inside the envelope
before is there some third thing that's
some kind of sender that's outside the
envelope so to speak anybody know what a
comment nicholas jason
well it's called the envelopes what is
being given to the to smell to or to
achieve to the mail that can be okay so
there's something else called sender
which for him is getting from the IMAP
you know from the IMAP transfer
mechanism so in IMAP you can precisely
ask for envelope information so that is
the information that I am displaying I'm
not doing anything to it and however RFC
defines it
that's the term I'm using I'm not making
up any mere information here so what
might have not happened is I didn't look
at EML and I don't know the
correspondence between RFC and the in
EML documentation okay so fine I think
we should try to follow what we've done
for ml as much as possible
right okay and what I'm suggesting here
is that what we do wherever that got to
yeah there we go
is that you know I guess we have to have
everything in this Association it's a
shame to have to repeat things but I
think it's still probably useful well
actually I mean what you're showing here
you already see in the summary who the
from that's why I have put it in this
way summary is something you find it
quickly yeah but this is the complete
information so we definitely want the
the from string here right as well as
this rules thing and we should be
getting able to get the rules from UML
okay let's take a look at what
everything is that you've got in this
list where was it I had everything about
this system is broken right now it's
scrolling like unbelievably slowly okay
so apart from that there are things that
are missing let's see
attachments will be what the filenames
or what
yes file names and file sizes and the
format well why don't you import the
thing so it's an actual expression
because then it will be really slow
right you don't want your input this is
a search result you don't want to import
everything while you're doing the search
you just want to get the useful
information
okay but this is then different I mean
what we're doing for text search is
we're returning content objects which
are lazy yeah yeah exactly that's what
it's not implemented yet so are you
suggesting then that the content objects
that we should use content objects but
that the visible version of the content
object should in this case be the email
summary yes that seems like a good idea
by the way that's not right you should
you know you should do the same kissed
Excel clients do of saying you know if
it's today you know if it's the you know
that that would be the time of day for
today because that's today right yes yes
okay so all right so then what we're
seeing here is mail search the the you
know mail search you're saying would
ultimately work more like I gosh I wish
this wasn't so slow what is going on
here um this is some interaction between
twitch OBS zoom and everything else okay
so in any case if we look at text search
then if we look here then what we're
doing let's take a look here we've got
so I run that index and then here what
I'm getting I can barely use this that's
not good um well what am I I'm running
11.3 right yes so that's probably why
this doesn't work okay so let's try
running
let's try running a release version
that's interesting that's probably for
you Nikolas over here okay fine all
right fine
so okay so then I do this I get this
whatever is happening here so that's
building an index so now in the case of
so this is how this is the analog of
what you were returning as mail server
object correct for him what I can do
with this is like what you can do with a
mail server object did we lose you
yes um so if I say text search of index
here comma fish or something oops what
this will do is it will return ok this
rather useless search result object why
are we let's see it is a is chiara with
us by the way is some why why are we
doing it this way what what is the point
of this why are we not returning the
list of content objects the list of
contents because this way we can display
information right oh I see what but but
but if we previewed the content objects
we would be able to do the same thing
right so here so I think we want to do
things like this way you I mean you can
extract him from a global information
like the the count to the the snippets
of oh I don't know this was the original
design
fair enough okay all right so so the
analog of that would be essentially the
data set what would happen I mean if we
just return the data set here if we
didn't return this cast last week and I
think it's it's something like yeah we
decided to try I think yeah okay but do
we need to have if the list is very long
is the idea that the subsequent pages
will be lazy somehow yeah yeah there was
the thing that we needed a lazy data set
in order to in order to be able to do
that I mean to do that properly
otherwise we'll it will take a long time
to load everything in possibly too much
time right but okay so what is the
analogue between content object and I
mean right now here we are returning a
data set for the complete results and
each element here is not a content
object and instead it just has the
actual raw text of the message and
potentially the attachments which for
him is saying is not going to work very
well because the attachments could be
huge right now a content object if I'm
not mistaken has the feature that it is
lazy loading is that true yeah it
doesn't actually have the content right
there yes it has the pointer to the
content fair enough but I mean that you
know at very least we could use a
content object mechanism for the
attachments where are the attachments
anywhere the attachments still on the
mail server yes okay all right
well okay so let's take a look at okay
so we still have a bit of a mess there
in my opinion search for a subset then
apply function yeah that's an
interesting thing so how would we do
that in your data set mechanism that
would work very nicely if we wanted to
for example find all those messages well
so how would we do it so give
what is what is the actual handle teach
message so let's say I wanted to search
these messages and find everyone that
was from a certain domain and delete all
those messages how would I do it right
so we haven't implemented anything but
you would have functions like delete
mail delete and then you would map over
a point here I'm not exactly sure what
that looks like yeah well so that's the
that's the place where we have trouble
so if content object if we were using
content object for example I could
imagine that we can say something like
mail delete of the content object and it
effectively has a handle to that mail
item see what I'm saying
whereas by the time you've exposed the
whole thing in this data set it's too
late
except maybe you do have something I
mean you can go to the message ID but
that's kind of hacky right but you could
also return just something like a
content object that actually points to
the mail on the server and if you delete
that if you fetch if you get a list of
that using the data set you don't have
the information but it's hidden in the
matter information of the object and
then you can delete it using mail delete
okay let me let me walk through that
again hold on let me we had some notes
from a previous time here about well
were they Sushma do you know where those
notes were the ones about um here we go
is this it yes this is it
um so this was our is this still current
or not
um okay
so let's walk through this again so the
trade-off is I mean we want something
where we would like it to be the case
that if you say okay so first of all you
have to do some connection and we
believe that that has to be and what's
it going to return it's going to return
a mail server object we think which then
in turn contains a bunch of folders is
that right
yes but the folders if I extract a
single folder what is it is it a mail
you know what is that and is it is the
is there a difference between a mail
server object and I mean you're naming
these individual folders mail object is
that correct yes what's the difference
in a mail server object and a mail
object mail object is the folder because
you fetch messages from the folder not
the server and once you have the folder
object that's what you were doing right
now when you did inbox equal and then
you did mail search of Inbox
no I understand that but why do we need
why what is the concept of a mail server
object that is different from just the
the tip of the hierarchy of mail folders
represented by mail objects see like in
a file system right the root is still a
file yes that's not the case in I mouth
well why is it different I mean we don't
you can't really say to the server right
that's the key importance you can't
extract messages you just can't do it
well I mean we could do it we could
build something that just you know maps
over all of them and it might be very
slow but we could perfectly well
absolutely so why don't we I mean
wouldn't that be simpler for people if
you say you connect to the mail server
you get back a mail object that mail
object since you've got hierarchical
folders anyway or is it is it the case
why are we not returning just a list of
the folders no that doesn't make sense
what walk me through okay so if I change
direct if I go to a particular mail
folder is it hierarchical or is it or am
I always going down to a specific you're
always going down to specific so if you
see your folder view that might be
suffle there but then you go to exact
folder you don't go to the folder above
it to get to the folder below it you go
to the exact one okay so what you're
saying is that if I would look here so
I've got ms folders there and I've got
all kinds of random folders right yes um
and okay all kinds of weird stuff here
which I should delete actually um okay
so you're saying from I mean when butBut
there's a default folder that I'm using
for mail search which is the inbox or
not no it's just like any other folder
although arguably it should be the
default yes but so what would that then
look like I mean so in other words we're
going we connect to the server we've got
a bunch of folders there but we have a
default folder that is used for mail
search is that right I mean so if I just
say mail search let's imagine that I'm
just saying mail search and I wish this
echoing this thing was echoing properly
um you know what I wonder if I use 11.2
whether this problem won't occur you
just try that um that looks bad as well
it's less bad slightly less bad okay so
if I say mail search your and I've got
you know some do we think we're going to
have a default place where the searches
or what it should be the end box you
know I understand but how is that
default going to be set up do we have
some kind of dollar we had something
kind of thing dollar mail inbox here
right which is the default thing that it
searches okay all right
well previously we talked about a mail
folder object and what's the difference
in a mail for right now we don't have a
mail object because everything that
comes out just as a okay so right now we
have the notion of a okay so we have
mail server connect I wish this typed
properly which then leads to a we claim
a mail server object which I don't like
very much
which then contains folders apparently
this is kind of weird I mean
why is it useful to ever see the mail
server object rather than a list of
folders I think that's better
to see just the folders so then if we
said for example forget about mail
Connect we just mail server connect we
just say mail connect and that then
returns a list of folders I mean that's
a little weird because maybe the only
reason you want mail connect well
actually if you have a default mail
server you may not need to use mail
Connect right
I mean then this would be how this is
getting really weird this is getting
really weird because you know what's the
a log with the file system so that first
of all that mail server is given by some
IMAP string together with earth and I
mean some URL together with
authentication information is that
correct yes
I mean if we just said okay so then what
comes back are that there are IMAP
addresses are there not for all the
folders that come back is that true or
is it in other words those subfolders do
they have a URL or not no I mean you
could make one but no okay okay and then
you sort of like how you work in a file
system okay um what let's walk through a
few more of these things
okay so mail item what was that well
item is what mail object it sort of
represents you would if you wanted to
delete my email you would delete a mail
item okay but then it should be the case
that a mail item displays with it as it
would in a mail client but that what
happens is that somehow mail search
returns a list of mail items now that's
different from what we're doing over
here we talked about returning a data
set here but then is it the case in that
data set that what we would do is we
would have snippet information together
with content objects would that be the
idea in that I was thinking but so
chiara is that what is that what we were
imagining for text search so in in text
search right we're talking about what is
what is in the data set right and so one
possibility is that there is snippet
information that each each element of
the data set contains snippet of
information that's human visible human
readable and then together with a
content object would that make sense yes
again if it is lazy well the content
object is lazy
right I mean the snippet is not lazy or
do we even think the snippet has to be
lazy no what I mean is that these data
set needs to be new right I understand
that if you have a large number of
search results we gotta have a lazy data
set I get that right so we can't I mean
I don't we don't want to generate
snippets for all results I see I see
you're saying that that in addition to
yeah well so basically all the elements
of the data set have to be lazy um is
that is somebody looking at that okay um
okay all right so back to this again
okay so we're still not okay so in that
case so is there any other function
that's like text search where we have to
have consistency with this oh that's
right what do they do right now web
search returns the data set doesn't it
so if I say web image search of aardvark
for example I think that's just going to
return a data set which is another good
reason for these other things to return
data sets
Yeah right I mean that's just a dataset
we don't have a lot of information there
because we you know we're not fetching I
mean we could potentially have a Content
object that represents a lazy version of
the back up of the page that is in the
hyperlink here right that will be the
analog of what we're doing here correct
but we're not choosing to do that yet
what happens with Wikipedia search does
it do the same thing as this does all
these pages of links I think what a mess
I was that's horrifying
that's just crazy that's wrong so who is
dealing with Wikipedia search does
anybody know here somebody under Allen
but does anybody Sushma do you know who
No okay so listen yeah we need to make
sure that this is consistent and I would
think what the PDS search needs to
return the same type of data set so look
what we probably should do is to
standardize on returning a data set Plus
content objects and the data set should
contain you know like here it has a
thumbnail obviously that's not relevant
for email but in the case of email we
would have the analog of a thumbnail
which is that summary box makes sense
and then the rest and then these other
things can be the various kinds of
computable elements together with in sub
somewhere in here a content object makes
sense okay now the question is if so
then if you extract that element
I mean arguably visually in the data set
we could make the content object have
some more iconic appearance so that it
would be the obvious thing to extract if
you're in column one here and then that
content object has all the back pointer
information so that you can basically
say male delete of that content object
if I'm not mistaken and it will go to
the mail server and delete it is that
also people's understanding that's how I
understand it okay and there's no
problem in terms of the way that content
objects have their metadata and so on
having having that back pointer just
like we have a reference location here
there's a perfectly reasonable to have
that reference location point back to
the mail server correct I'll have to
think about that particular thing but
there's something really funky about the
fonts in this content object I don't
know who's this who that is kara do you
know anything about that
who is who is pianning the search stuff
okay so can can we get Fatima to go
chase that okay okay so now given that
content object for example the flags of
the mail message would be okay so so
this data set can include all the mail
message flags correct yes that might be
in the content object but they might
also be in the they might be highly
visible and I don't know how you've set
it up like with your summary are you
indicating what's been read and what's
unread no not yet okay fine but so that
can be there but that can also be a
column that represents those flags what
are the flags that exist they things
like they're read and unread you go
ahead yes so there is answered which
means you have replied to it seen which
means you have read it
and a few other ones custom ones I think
you can and then there is flagged which
means it has been flagged flagged for
what purpose no it's just a flag you
know like the red thing that appears on
the mail client okay so how we want to
present those a little bit non-trivial
because we probably want it to be
programmatically easy for somebody to
say what all my unread mess I guess I
guess that's easy you can just fine okay
but that's not an obvious thing because
that subsetting right
so when you say flags goes to answered
what is how do you specify that you want
something with the specific flags
flagged and answered don't we have the
same issue in in text go ahead what
we're going to say nothing do we have
the same issue and text search of when
we are looking for a any subset versus
the exact match for the fields and text
search Nicholas Chiara no I understand
but do we have a case where it's
subsetting so in this in this case what
Fahim is saying is that you can say
flags arrow answered right and what that
will give you is all messages where the
flags element contains answered right
yeah I understand but but that's the the
problem here is that the flags look
basically the point here is that what
really we should do is to have a thing
called flags list which is a list of all
the flags that have been set on a given
message right but then the question is
what does it look like when you just
want to find you know in other words
what is the do you get what I'm saying
you you want to be able to have a simple
select that goes through and finds
without having to go to levels down that
finds on you know the unread messages
for example to get what I'm saying and
by the way that Flags thing from what
you're describing the flags to be unread
is an absence of seen etc etc etc right
so that's a slightly more complicated
query to get that so we want something
where it's easy to to see that so that
that's let's not address this full issue
right now with flags but you you get
what I'm saying I think that's not right
I think we can do better than that I
think we can have something where yeah I
mean you know one way to do it obviously
will be to break it apart as a as each
flag corresponds to a separate element
of the associate of the top-level
Association for the message okay
so that what you get is answered arrow
true answered are a false flag there
yeah that's the right way to do it I
think if you think about it that that
that's gonna be the right way to do it
because much more often you're going to
want to say I want all messages that are
you know not seen for example so that
means that you want messages for which
the seen you know seen as false to get
what I'm saying
yes so I think that's the right way to
do it so we should break the flags apart
into the sort of top level of that
Association now what do we do to reset
the flags what do we do I mean only
certain things can be reset in these
content objects you can't go and check
the message right so I'm app allows you
to delete it move it
change the flags but not so so then we
have but we should be able to take an
EML or whatever that is and put it on
your drafts that's totally possible oh
that's interesting
so how do we you can put it in any kind
of I I had the prototype sometime ago
okay so that's another thing we have to
think about so but-but-but what we need
to do then is the setting of flags is
something where we have to say front of
the content of it so do we have any
precedent for this in other uses of
content objects where you're resetting
elements of content objects does anybody
know no is that a no you don't know
where is that I know we haven't done it
right now yeah I understand I understand
this is somewhat different I mean this
happens it happens to be a different
back-end um okay
so so then we need something which
allows us to modify a content object so
what would be another model for that
else where we'd want something where you
say what would we do I mean we would
have set options would be a typical way
of doing this or alternatively we would
have you know an l-value based on the
content object am I making sense so that
we would have literally yeah
I mean I wonder whether we could do it
with set options I wonder whether that's
a crazy way to do it what is inside a
Content object is a Content object what
are these things but what does the
wrapper look like is this a single
association inside so okay so it in a
slight abuse we might be able to use set
options on a Content object so the way
that would look is something like you
know scene arrow true
and we're making sense it's a little
weird but we need some operation like
that that would change the elements I
mean what will be the literal thing that
we will be doing the literal thing we'd
be doing is a replace part that right I
think we'd be doing a replaced part on
the content object but that would not
push it back into that's not an l-value
type thing that's just saying take my
copy of that content object and do this
to it that's not pushing it back to the
source of the content object like an
l-value that makes sense but I mean but
set options conceivably could be made to
do that yes okay so we need something
like that now notice that set options if
the content object contained its folder
sourcing from it you know what folder it
was from right then in principle set
options could reset that folder and if
set options attempts to reset something
that is not resettable like the you know
the from address or something then it
will just give an error that makes sense
yes
but then you know what you want as a
convenience I mean we could have a
convenience like your mail move function
I'm not hugely keen on that name um yeah
I mean the question is do we mind about
having a bunch of these extra things
okay so in this current model we are
getting rid of mail item and what's
happening is that mail search and mail
connect are both returning so mail
Connect would potentially return a data
set of folders what are the folders now
the folders what are the folders are the
folders just these data sets that
contain content objects no no mail
folders one contain any it's just a
point here well then were bored how do
we represent it it's it's a mail object
yeah but ok what's the analog of a male
object what it what if the male folder
was also a Content object that just
happens to be male father I mean just
like you know origin of species isn't a
male folder but it is a Content object
it could be I mean that's the point I
mean that's really a point well so maybe
the thing in the economy of objects
maybe what should happen is that the
folders should be content objects as
well and that what we should return from
male Connect well it doesn't really
matter what we return from male Connect
that's not the most important thing
actually the one thing we need to have
for male connectors if we're going to
have a male disconnect it's going to
return a thing that allows you to
disconnect am I making sense yes
let's see so um so how is that going to
work so what is mail connect what could
mail connect return
I mean Cloud Connect rather uselessly
returns like a return something pretty
useless and cloud disconnect doesn't
take that handle but can you have
multiple you there's no reason why you
can't have multiple mail connects
running at the same time right so it has
to return some kind of symbolic
representation of the connection to the
mail server yes that's why the mail
server object exists I understand um
okay but what is the analogy do we have
an analog of that elsewhere of a live
thing that's been connected to for
example the service connections are
things where there is a live thing that
was connected to right and that what
does service what does service connect
return a service object well maybe
that's what we should do here it's the
only reason why that why that is a bad
idea for this all right we discussed
this because it's not expandable and
IMAP is more precise will you make it
potentially there is no reason why we
can't but then it would be a little bit
inconvenient why
it would be more difficult for users to
actually know that it is a server and
then the search is going to be more
bizarre in service execute I think no no
we don't want to put that into service
execute okay silly no I'm not suggesting
that I'm suggesting that we have that
male connectors there but the male
connect returns a service object but
then you would want to use service
execute because that's what you don't
need to do that you can perfectly well
use mail search on a service object then
people might want to use Twitter on the
mail search you see if mail search can
take service object why can't you give
it any kind of because it's Twitter is
not mail so it's kind of silly in our
representation it is still a service
object maybe well I'm not sure look I
mean the fact is we're not just going to
support IMAP we're gonna support a bunch
of other mail protocols and are they all
representable what is the difference
between a generic service object and the
whole diverse zoo of mail protocols I
mean only IMAP is the most useful one
there is REST API but they are
controlled by well I understand that but
we want something which is plug
compatible I mean you know as far as the
user is concerned the functionality
should be as similar as possible and
those rest api is fit very well with the
service object paradigm right
I think am I missing something I mean
cuz that's what a lot of those services
are rest api's am i wrong and they are
all exclusively arrests api's okay fine
so that's an argument for using service
object as the return from male connect
so that it is is opaque it doesn't
matter whether it's an IMAP or a REST
API or what it is or some future weird
you know thing but by the way does
anybody want to comment Jason or
Nicholas or anybody want to comment or
whether there are other mail protocols
that we care about or male connection
mechanisms that we care about okay yeah
pop is pretty dead isn't it I mean but
but okay so fine let's let's I still
think I'm still supporting the idea of
trying to shoehorn this into service
object rather than having our own
separate a separate mail connection
object and then I'm trying to you know
I'm pushing the idea right now we have a
mess of incompatibility between these
different search types and I think we
should standardize on returning data
sets containing contact objects I think
these content objects we need a
mechanism for pushing stuff back into
the content objects and I think we need
and by the way one of the things that's
nice we don't need if this is returned
as a data set then anything which is
local analytics you can just do by
essentially mapping over the data set
we're making sense
and things which are pushing back to the
server you will extract from the data
set the content object and then use its
essentially back pointers to push the
stuff back to the server so there is the
question of whether we want I mean I
think there's a certain argument that
you know I'm wondering whether like we
have service executes whether we should
have you know delete set flags move
etcetera etcetera etcetera
as part of a male action or some such
other thing function rather than
breaking them all apart
anybody got comments on that otherwise
we have because that way we can have
things like oh actually I have a comment
on that if we have besides functions
well yeah you could map them over the
data set well okay the question is what
functions do we need you think we need
male delete male move and the rather
bizarre male set Flags that correct yes
I think those are the most used
functions that people do with that male
client so that's why I have them but
okay all right what was this thing here
this male monitor submit thing that has
to do with oh I see that's setting up a
continuous task to monitor the mail
server is that something we're closed
tour is that something we don't worry
well it's not very okay so you wanted to
do it outside the kernel session which
might which is outside my domain inside
the kernel session then you say but what
I would like to do is have a task object
that is returned using this male monitor
that actually sees incoming messages
right now there is no way to do that why
does male Connect not return at some
kind of task object thing it could but
you want it to return a service object I
know that I know that I'm seeking having
it not return a new kind of thing um
what should it I mean a service object
is something that will be poked at by
various operations a task object well
what's the difference here I mean a task
object where is not used to having
operations having yeah I mean a task
object it's just the task is just
running and the task has various
handlers but the task is the one that's
generating the information rather than
you kicking the task in some way right
we don't have it we don't really but now
what you're saying is what happens if
you want to do both those things so you
you want to get the task you want to get
a task from the I mean you know from the
mail server and that task what are you
gonna do with that task you're gonna
have handlers of various kinds to
represent because that way you can keep
the connection open check for messages
every five minutes and so on what it
could have a task object as a matter
information that you could extract from
either the service object or the mail
server object you could extract that
well I don't think we want some random
task lying around do
I mean if you just wanted to do this
once and you don't want to update your
mail in real time in your session you're
just doing an analysis of some kind you
don't really want the tasks hanging
around fair enough um so right but I
mean this mail monitors submit it's kind
of cool mail submit I don't know what no
mail monitors submit is probably the
right thing and then what it would do is
but what would it what would it send as
its handler function keys that is what
would it send back
okay new message received I guess it
sends back the content object that
represents that new message that's fine
okay I think we have much of the design
here there are okay further questions
issues to bring up nope anybody other
thing all right well that's um sounds
good so we will unfortunately this is a
bit of a mess these notes sushma from me
are a bit of a mess because I because of
my stupid non echoing Mouse I'll try and
clean these up and I'll save them okay
and all right I don't well then
everybody's been paying attention to
this on Twitch if they have I hope they
had fun we at least made some progress
here so hopefully anybody who's watching
this coming to a Wolfram language
version near you quite soon will be what
we discussed here hopefully I hope
depends on everybody here all right
great end of our pilot twitch